her feet have barely touched the ground
since winning the u.s open being a grand
slam champion brings many extra demands
but for emma radhakanu her life really
changed after wimbledon wimbledon was
the first moment for me where you know i
was really being like competitive on a
global scale i feel and uh obviously
there was so much excitement going on
and adrenaline like i've never felt
before because that was the first time
and uh i mean i was so so proud and
happy but being at home playing in front
of a home crowd i think it was such a
special feeling and especially out there
on court one it was the biggest court
i've ever played on so the way that i
went out there i feel i was quite
nervous but
yeah i just absolutely loved it once i
got out there and the home crowd was
just such a such a great pleasure to
play in front of
and talk us through the us open which
you sort of touched on but you know how
did the three weeks evolve that you were
there competing you know did you have to
keep upgrading your goals
well i
it was so funny i i arrived in new york
just just hoping to get through
qualifying maybe i mean i was pretty
tired but um
i
i just had the most amazing time and i
think nikita that i was honestly so
focused on on the day that the time flew
by and uh
it went so fast by the end of it me and
my team were just having a great time
and for me i was like i don't want to
leave yet you know i want to stay and
and then it was getting to the latter
stages of the tournament and i was i was
really thinking oh but what if like
you're here like you can you know why
not you must have got more and more
excited though as you went on and how
did you sort of keep that
under control it was great because out
there i had a great circle of people who
are close to me and we we just went
about every single day as normal you
know that we weren't getting
into
any of the really extra excitement it
was just between us you know keeping the
routines the exact same thing and i
think that's what really worked you know
everything was the same and no one made
a big deal out of it
are you superstitious did you have to
sort of keep wearing the same socks
well i actually wasn't until maybe like
the last week where i was thinking like
okay i was having pokey for dinner every
single night and
then by the for three weeks
and then by the end i was i just kept it
the same because i didn't want to take
any chances what do you think about when
you when you think of new york you know
what pops into your head after what you
achieved is it are you proud are you
still slightly in disbelief you know
what it what is it
yeah i think that the best memories i
have of new york as is just of the
amount of fun i had out there and
i i definitely felt like i faced my own
sort of obstacles and the way i overcame
those and for example the first time i
stepped out onto ash i was quite nervous
and i didn't realize until i really
started i got off to a slow start but
then the way that i overcame that and by
the end i was completely thriving out
there in front of so many people you
can't win every match as a tennis player
you know everybody knows that but how do
you cope with the raised expectations of
other people outside the sport now that
you've you've won a grand slam yeah i
feel like people are going to have
opinions and expectations of me but i
don't really think about that at all and
to me it doesn't really matter the only
the only thing that matters to me is my
expectations of myself and what i want
to achieve or what i want to get out of
the day and it's it's just about
improving you know seeing yourself get
better what did you learn about yourself
in this year
in this year i learned i was pretty
resilient i'd say
um because it there were like a lot of
ups and downs i mean of course i didn't
play tennis
for three months at all at the beginning
of the year like i didn't pick up a
racquet and i was sitting my a levels
and
you know i was like thinking when is my
next tournament going to be and then at
wimbledon i had an incredible experience
and then yeah i
physically
was tired at the end of it and uh
yeah but i bounced back from that went
out to the states and i had a great
swing so it's just up and down but uh
being resilient and smoothing out that
curve do you have any non-tennis targets
i mean i don't know if you can drive for
example
are there any things you want to do
not related to tennis
yeah there are many many things i mean i
have my driver's license but i'm like a
big adrenaline junkie and like motor
sports fan but um i'd say
maybe get my motorbike license i hope or
you know something really like speedy
and fun and just continue to
like really push to push the boundaries
of that because i find it i just get
such a thrill from it somewhat 2021 in a
word
2021 was a surprise
and a journey those two i couldn't pick
2022 will be emma's first full year on
the tour so there are many journeys
ahead but she's proud of how far she's
come
jackie beltral sky sports